district 9 is an uncommonly smart sci-fi
hit and it's got a heck of a lot going
on especially in the final act did you
come away wondering what really happened
or musing on what could happen next
not to worry this is the ending of
district 9 explain when most films end
audiences are treated to powerful soft
light shots of the hero kissing their
love interests hugging their relatives
or celebrating their great victory over
the antagonists but district 9 has no
clear-cut heroic ending in fact given
how much of the story revolves around
thickest vonda more of a slowly
succumbing to a horrible disease if
you're not paying close attention to the
ending you may end up wondering is Vic
us even alive is he lying in a ditch
somewhere
did the Nigerian mercenaries finally eat
his body for magical powers
well don't worry Vic us is very much
alive at the conclusion of the film
unfortunately he's also very much an
alien we know this because Vic is's wife
finds a metal flower made out of trash
left on her front doorstep which she
believes may have come from him
the very next shots is an alien making
another flower
so either Vic is's wife has a secret
admirer amongst the prawn community or
Vic as himself is leaving her small
tokens to let her know he's okay common
sense would suggest it's probably the
latter it's pretty clear that Vic US
becomes a full-on alien by the end of
district 9 and you'd be forgiven for
wondering if there is any scrap of
humanity left in him at all throughout
the film Vika slowly loses control of
himself and acts in increasingly strange
alien ways
that said the flower biggest leaves his
wife is as good an indication as any
that Vika still clings to at least some
of his humanity earlier in the film Vika
sustains that he loves making her fun
craft projects
it seems that alien Vika still feels
that urge to let his wife know he's
generally doing okay and hasn't fully
lost his personality
even if he's a little slimy er than the
last time she saw him if you look
closely at Vickers post transformation
it's also clear that one of his eyes
retains its blue human color while the
other is green like those are the other
prawns this would indicate that there's
still a small portion of Vika switch
remains human and retains at least some
of his previous memories he's certainly
more prawn than man but that doesn't
mean he's lost all of his humanity at
the end of district 9 the prawn named
Christopher who fights alongside Vickers
throughout the film ultimately escapes
the planet thanks to Vick is's sacrifice
and assistance Christopher is able to
get his damaged command module working
and fly himself in his son up to the
recently activated mothership of course
one question remains how long will it be
before Christopher is able to return to
Earth he promised to cure Vikas of his
illness after all how long will Vikas be
forced to wait earlier in the film
Christopher convinces Vickers to help
him by assuring him he can reverse Vick
is's slowly worsening disease but after
learning about the government's
experimentation on his people
Christopher tells Vika she needs to
alert his people to what's happening
before he can dedicate the necessary
time in Alien fuel needed to heal Vikas
Christopher estimates it'll take him
three years to make the trip to and from
his home planet back to earth so
Christopher will return but it's more
than likely the biggest will be forced
to live as a pran for at least three
years until then speaking of those human
on prawn experiments just how excited do
we think alien High Command will be
about Christopher's story even without
all the brutal torture and
experimentation aliens have been treated
as second-class citizens abused and
manipulated by citizens of Earth for
nearly three decades we don't know much
about alien culture but we do know they
have some hugely impressive technology
including powerful guns and exoskeleton
power suits it's hard to imagine they
don't have a mil
of some sorts and who knows what other
crazy weapons or bombs they might have
on their home planet victus may have
slightly softened Christopher's opinion
of humans but Christopher is still
clearly upset about what's happened to
his people either way there's surely no
way to explain what's going on at
district 9 that won't antagonize the
pron leadership and if the aliens return
with any sort of retribution on their
mind
humanity is probably completely screwed
one of the largest unanswered questions
at district 9 is just why the alien fuel
actually turns humans into prawns it's
clear Vick is's transformation starts
when the fluid is sprayed into his face
but nobody ever figures out exactly why
things go the way they do even weirder
Christopher doesn't seem at all confused
when Vickie's transforms he immediately
knows the fluid would do that and seems
highly confident that the medical
machines on the mothership could heal
vicious are you saying that you can you
can turn this this is the throne and
Eater into a human and you can might be
you interestingly it also appears that
alien fuel plays some role in healing
humans because Christopher says he needs
all the available fuel to travel quickly
which is why it'll take a while to heal
thickest the fuel brings up all kinds of
possible implications for the future of
the district 9 universe for example
could other humans accidentally become
prawns is there more alien technology
containing the fuel out there amongst
the trash heaps is it possible the
prawns themselves could weaponize the
fuel in such a way as to transform all
of humanity lots of future scenarios
could play out on earth thanks to that
fluid and most of them don't exactly
bode well for Humanity check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more blooper videos about your favorite
stuff or coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]